okay so stranger things is back with its
fourth season that feels longer than the
weight we had between this and the last
one i don't care though i love it and
this entry is one of if not my favorite
season that we've ever had one of the
last genuine mega hits that netflix have
yet to cancel the execs have changed up
their binge model and they've given us
the first seven episodes with the latter
two dropping on july 1st in this new
entry we have several storylines going
on such as 11 taking a trip down memory
lane dustin and co attempting to get to
the bottom of a made a mystery joyce and
murray trying to save hopper and hopper
trying to survive the harsh prison that
is kamchatka the first two threads in
this connect together as do the last two
and there's a lot of things that we
learn about in this first volume that
perfectly sets things up for next time
throughout this video we're going to be
turning it up to 11 and going through it
all so sit back relax and please hit
that thumbs up button also make sure you
subscribe as we're going to be doing
videos on this show every week in the
lead up to the second volume before we
do a deep dive on that as well there's
never been a better time to be part of
the heavy spoilers family and with that
out of the way let's get into stranger
things four now this is the story all
about how becca's life got flipped
turned upside down
so one of the most terrifying aspects of
the new season is wekner a humanoid
creature from the upside down who traps
his prey in a fantasy before he brutally
murders them in eye-popping fashion in
the build up to this the characters
become lost in a fantasy and they start
to see vivid hallucinations that appear
similar to a nightmare that they can't
escape from i definitely got lots of
nightmare on elm street vibes from this
and we get not only a mention of freddy
krueger but also a cameo by robert
englund at one point given the name the
hellfire club he's assigned this because
in dungeons and dragons wekner was a
powerful wizard that became a leech aka
an undead creature this actually turns
out to be true as well as we discover
his backstory through 11. now the season
opens with her as a child apparently
murdering all the other subjects in
brennan's experiment but as the series
goes on we discover this isn't the truth
there's even a hint towards this
eventual reveal in this owning moment as
we see a tear on the wall behind her
which we learn is where she sent beckner
into the upside down now early on 11
really struggles to fit in at high
school and after being publicly
embarrassed she ends up losing her cool
and attacking her high school bully this
allows dr owens to come to her as a
friend and after he tricks her into
working with brenna once more she
eventually agrees to go into a machine
he's crafted that's called nina this
will apparently give her back her powers
but i think brenna also clearly wants to
know what really happened on the day
that she wiped out all of his subjects
although nina isn't explained in full
the way it works is that it allows
eleven to somewhat travel into her
subconsciousness and she can revisit her
childhood going through the steps in
which she gained her powers will also
revitalize them in the future and allow
her to possess her abilities once more
their disappearance is likely
psychosomatic and just like how peter
lost his abilities in spider-man 2 for a
bit she likely lost hers through stress
as well now in nina we discover how a
friendly totally not evil orderly helped
her with her bullies the bullies here of
course reflect the one she has in high
school and a maybe he's a nice guy well
he's not and come the end of episode 7
we discover that he's actually the son
of victor creel the apparent killer that
supposedly butchered his family in an
amityville-esque night of horror the
young creel moved to hawkins with his
family and as his powers started to
develop he slowly [ __ ] himself off from
the world he found kinship with black
widow spiders potentially even setting
up his feature relationship with a
spider-like mind player now creel
disliked societal constructs and the
basic nature of life he believed that
people were stuck in a constant
monotonous cycle trapped reliving the
same days over and over until they died
this explains why clocks keep being seen
by his victims and why time becomes such
a big motif in this entry now creel
couldn't pretend to live a normal life
and his true powers started to form he
learned he could see into people's minds
and after witnessing what his parents
got up to he decided that enough was
enough and that he'd never forgive them
for lying about santa i'll never forget
we also actually get the music used in
watchmen for dr manhattan's origin story
to tell his one which was a nice touch
now though we don't learn all the ins
and outs of what his parents did i think
we will probably discover this more as
we get into the second volume or
potentially they could just leave it up
in the air we do know that his father
had just come back from the second world
war where he carried out something that
he massively regretted and his mother
well
knows if i'll ever understand what goes
on in a woman's head i'm alright fellas
anyway one fateful night he murdered his
mother and sister however his powers
overloaded before he could finish the
job on his dad his father had the crimes
pinned on him and creel was taken in by
brenner which is when he started up his
program creel is officially number one
and he's where it all hawkens back to
now brenna was unable to control him but
he wanted to duplicate his abilities and
thus he started his plan to create two
through to 11. brenner placed an
inhibitor chip on him that made it so he
couldn't use his powers and he was
enlisted as an orderly unable to leave
the lab his goal was to simply have this
ripped out of his neck and thus he
somewhat manipulated eleven into taking
out what he called a tracking device so
that the pair could both escape however
upon this happening he started murdering
the other test subjects and though he
wanted eleven to join him she turned
down this offer here's an 11 zar
culminated with her sending him through
a tear in the upside down which is where
he transformed into wechner this links
back to season 1 and we learned that the
entire landscape of the upside down is
exactly the same as how it was on the
day that will was pulled into it time
doesn't actually progress in this dark
dimension and everything there is
exactly the same as how it was on that
fateful day now i see this ending is not
only being the supervillain origin story
for him but it's also very much the tale
of 11 getting her powers back this is of
course setting up a massive showdown
between the pair come the second volume
but she's beat him once and i think she
can beat him again i think that this
will end up leading her back to hawkins
and she'll be reunited with her friends
once more and potentially hopper after
joyce brings him back this will make it
so that she can remain there and protect
the area from other threats like vechna
however whether brenner is willing to
give her up is another story altogether
and i hope she says papa don't preach
and that she also takes him out as well
he is still a bad guy even though this
season it does does paint him out in a
slightly better light but i'll never
forget i'll never forget now this video
is sponsored by established titles one
of the best and funnest gifts you can
give someone as many of you know i'm
from newcastle which is sort of on the
border of scotland so am i scottish
in a way now did you know there's a
traditional scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as lads lords or
ladies that's why i was super interested
in this project which allows you to get
at least one square foot of dedicated
land on a private estate in ordally
aberdeenshire or scotland so if you pick
up a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst helping to preserve the
picturesque woodlands of scotland it's a
great way to help out the environment as
well as established titles will plant
one tree with every single order they
work with global charities like one tree
planet and trees for the future to
support global reforestation efforts and
also comes with this a bit of an ego
boost along with the trees that are
planted you can officially change your
name to lord on things like credit cards
plane tickets even your dating profile
they give you an official certificate
confirming your lordship yeah you love
it and this also contains a unique plot
number showing the exact location of
your land i am lord heavy spoilers bow
before me you punk memorial day is right
around the corner and established titles
have put together a sale where you can
claim an additional 10 percent off any
purchase i've linked it in the
description below and all you have to do
to claim this offer is go to
establishtitles.com
slash heavy spoilers and enter the code
heavy spoilers at the checkout that
gives you the extra 10 off it makes for
a great last minute gift and you get to
call yourself a lord so i bid the
farewell noble i shall see thee in the
next part of the video
goodbye fellow lord now though 11
probably has her powers back should
wekner prove more than a match for her
there are other ways to take him down
early on in the season max ended up
being put under his spell and her
friends tried to figure out a way to
save her before it was too late there
was even one point where i thought the
theories about billy being wekner were
true but these turned out to be just the
creators playing with us as it was
revealed to be an illusion still she
tried everything that she could to clear
her conscience over his death but it
wasn't enough in the end she's taken to
the upside down and we even see a grave
with myers written on it a nod to
halloween and the serial killer that max
also dressed up as off topic i also
thought the name baez was a twist on
myers but i digress now it seems like
it's curtains for her but due to the
magic of friendship yay her pals figure
out that something you love can be used
to tell you back to reality in this
volume it's running up that hill by kate
bush which she constantly listens to so
that wekner can't get a hold of her i
also think that lucas might end up being
the one to bring her back in volume 2.
in this season he's a far cry from what
he was in the others and at the start of
it he's not really in their friendship
group anymore lucas is now a member of
the hawkins tigers and he ends up
choosing their big championship game
over the hellfire clubs dungeons and
dragons campaign he gets replaced by his
sister who continues to be one of the
funniest characters in the entire show
and the song by kate bush that allows
her to leave the upside down matches the
problems that lucas and max have as kate
said i was trying to say that really a
man and a woman can't understand each
other because we are a man and a woman
and if we could actually swap each
other's roles if we could actually be in
each other's places for a while i think
we both be very surprised but it can't
do the voice yet but you get the idea no
lucas slowly starts to drift back to
them i don't think that he's gonna be a
pivotal person in helping to defeat
bechner he might end up showing his love
for dungeons and dragons and basketball
which could be used as a weapon either
way there's very much this idea that
love will save the day when it comes to
the characters and we have a number of
relationships in the season that could
end up being used to defeat the bad guy
there's of course lucas and max joyce
and hopper who we'll talk about later on
steve and potentially nancy 11 and mike
dustin and his girlfriend and yeah just
lots of characters we do learn that
durstin is still with his girlfriend and
we get several war games references
during the hacking scenes still bangs as
well go watch war games now there's also
the new editions of eddie and argyle who
both feel like love letters to 80s
movies eddie shares the name of iron
maiden's mascot and argyle reminds me a
lot of spicoli from fast times at
richmond high in the trailer we actually
get a moment where eddie can be seen
thrashing his guitar in the upside down
and it is possible that he uses this as
a method to help defeat wekner later on
now throughout the season the party gets
split up as we have one side hunting for
eddie who's framed for one of vechna's
murders and the other side trying to
prove it wasn't him eventually they
discover how to locate tears to the
upside down and steve robin nancy and
eddie break on through to the other side
this is where they discover more about
it and in the normal world dustin and
his pals find a way to communicate with
them and they launch an attempt to get
them out however as nancy climbs through
she's taken by wekner and not only does
she discover barbara's body she also
learns about the bad guy's past now we
don't actually see what happens to her
and come the end of this volume she is
trapped down there with beckner the
creel home is often referred to as the
boiler room and this could be a further
nod to nightmare on elm street beckner
actually takes 11 to 1 as well and as
i've been saying it's either like poetry
they rhyme or it's all connected you can
pick whatever crap punch line you want
to make you hate yourself slightly less
there now i think that the next episode
we're gonna get wekner filling in more
of the gaps as he keeps her prisoner
he's also gonna torment her over the
death of barbara it could finally be
hashtag justice for bob probably not
though but we will definitely see now
they might riff on elm street even more
and have wekner pulled into the real
world in the films that was where
freddie was at its most vulnerable and
it's also where eleven defeated him i do
think fekno will show up in the right
side up as we know he can make tears
anywhere on hawkins and this could be
used to launch his invasion i think
that'll happen once eleven is reunited
with hopper whose story i wanna tackle
for the next part of the video before we
move into our review and then i'll let
you guys go home now for the second time
in less than a year we catch david
harbour in a russian prison and we
discovered that he jumped down to a
walkway during the star court mall
explosion i was kind of hoping that he
would have jumped through the tear but
they do simplify that quite a lot and
either way things kind of go the way
that everyone knew they would because
that post credit scene it did give a lot
away now he was of course captured and
taken to kamchatka and then he meets a
friendly god called enzo a man who like
american and does not care about country
now relaying a message to joyce and
murray they travel to russia and try to
aid in hopper's great escape they even
give nodes to that movie and ends their
refers to hopper's steve mcqueen at one
point which is rift on with his escape
on a snowmobile that ends in a capture
as we learn in the post-credits scene of
season 3 the prisoners are often fed to
the demogorgon and there's even sadistic
gladiator games that they place them
into after enzo is found to have
betrayed the russians he's locked up
alongside hopper and it's easily the
most taoist story in the entire season
now before getting into this entry i was
expecting hopper to get out early on but
he remains in the prison for the entire
run with us only getting his reunion
with joyce come the close of his ark in
episode vii this was a pretty standard
affair story-wise but i love the last
suburb that the prisoners had making
them believe they were getting the treat
of a life sentence it was just really
fattening them up so they'd be better
meals and to keep the demogorgon
entertained so that it didn't become
bored and stop hunting the beast is
still alive and potentially it might
even be unleashed next time if it
manages to make it out the prison it was
such a brutal battle and watching the
demogorgon take out scores of people
showed how powerful it was at one point
hopper used a spear that he'd set on
fire hearkening back to ancient battles
with beasts from myths and legends
dustin also has a spear at one point in
the trailer teasing at this motif
potentially showing up again for volume
two now i really hope that they don't
waste too much time with getting him
back to america and with there being two
episodes left i can imagine they'll move
things along quickly i know these
episodes are going to be as long as a
feature-length film but i think that
come the end of the finale he'll be back
in the good old us of strange now hopper
is also another element that i think is
going to massively play into 11's
abilities and she's basically got these
two father figures in her life brenner
and hopper could both be used to
strengthen her but one wants what's best
for her whereas the other wants what's
best for him who knows we might even get
a hopper brenner showdown but i think
his reunion with 11 is gonna be a major
aspect for the next volume her becoming
a teen and him becoming a quote-unquote
father caused a lot of issues last
season but now they've been through a
lot and will likely realize how much
they mean to each other now there are a
wide range of unanswered questions that
this volume leaves after venturing into
the upside down max managed to draw what
she saw which turned out to be the creel
house will was also mentioned to have
been withdrawn in weird by 11 in the
opening possibly linking into this he
clutched a painting at one point but we
never saw what this was it might have
been nothing but it could also be
significant as his drawings have been
major plot points in the previous
seasons the upside down also seems to be
tied into him quite a lot as it's stuck
in 1983 like sunderland hey got your
punks i've already got you see you chump
it all feels like it's kind of tight at
both kreel and will and though the
ladder took a bit of a back seat this
season he's still really connected to
the dimension the lights are also a
mystery as they played a key role with
will communicating with joyce in season
1 and we might see how light or more
specifically electricity is different in
the upside down lastly the california
lot were able to acquire the program of
the nina machine and though this story
did get a bit lost amongst the rest i've
no doubt it will dovetail into the 11
plot i'm also interested to see if they
keep up the coke narrative they have
coca-cola classic and she used new coke
in the last season and before that just
a regular one now i do really want to
see the full gang back together and i
think they're all going to have to
reunite in order to stop this new threat
in vechna the first volume very much
feels like it's pulling all the
characters back together as you have
lucas and the hellfire club joining up
joyce and hopper 11 and brenner and come
next time i think we will get an end
game-esque battle where they all unite
as mentioned earlier that releases in
july and it's going to be interesting to
see what they do with it
now as with my thoughts on the season i
really really enjoyed this one and i
think they stepped up massively in terms
of quality storytelling effects acting
and the overall production of the show
the series feels very cinematic
throughout and it's constantly awash
with incredible visuals and moments that
rank up there is being some of the best
in the entire series now the season is
very long with almost all of the
episodes being over an hour i didn't
really mind it all that much but i do
think they could have cut some things
down like the basketball team story and
a lot of the earlier sections that
didn't really go anywhere i do really
wish that netflix had released these
episodes weekly as i think at this point
that's probably the best way to go about
things judging off the strategies that
the other streaming services have disney
plus amazon and hbo max all remain
bigger talking points for months and
months because they give us a slow burn
and with almost all of these episodes
ending on a cliffhanger i think that
would have worked way better it's just
weird to me that netflix replaced
blockbuster because they refused to
alter their business model and now
netflix are losing subscribers and their
audience because they refuse to do the
same too totally off topic and i know
some people they they hate weekly
releases but for me this show would have
hit harder if i was sitting from
saturday to thursday wondering what we
were gonna get next still though i can't
really fault this first volume and it's
got me so hyped up for what's around the
corner overall this was brilliant and it
gets a 9 out of 10. now i'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the series
if you pick the comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one on screen right now save
that to you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want emails to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of this week's other big
release obi-wan kenobi which will be
linked on screen right now you better go
over there i mean i'm using the force go
over there now
i'll see you there you punk you damn
chump you jump some of a [ __ ]
you